The only thing that is constant is change.
Everything around us is always changing
We see things moving, the weather keeps changing,
prices of things are always changing.
The temperature of the earth keeps rising.
Our population keeps increasing
and many more such changes.
Wouldn't it be amazing if we can predict
how things are going to change?
Well in many cases,
Calculus is the branch of mathematics that can do this.
For example,
calculus is used for analyzing the motion of objects
and then to build the models
to predict the trajectory of things like rockets.
It can be used to analyze the money coming in and out
of a business
and then to build models to maximize its profit.
Calculus can be referred to
as the mathematics of change.
So to develop the skill of predicting
change in the upcoming set of videos
we are going to understand the basic concepts of
Calculus.
Limits, differentiation and integration
are the important ideas around which calculus is built.
First we'll understand these ideas
in calculus if we mostly study things
which change according to a pattern.
These patterns of change
are mathematically represented by the
concept of functions
So the concept of functions is the main
object of study in calculus.
And therefore, we will understand it well.
And finally,
we will see how to use the ideas of limits, differentiation
and integration to analyze functions.
So to see a positive change in your knowledge of
mathematics,
watch the upcoming videos to understand the
basics of calculus.